[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm just here to provide some high-level
analyst view uh
our own perspective on
um on technology trends
um
i'll be focusing on two things i think
the two
takeaways from this will be
one
perhaps
understanding the balance of um
demand expectations
and efficiency gains to be derived as a
justification for
technology upgrades
and secondly as sort of a shift of the
balance from
pure connectivity
towards a kind of software layer
within within ftth
as a
the principal
technology driver
so
somebody said to me yesterday for
heaven's sake don't start your
presentation with a demand forecast
so hey there we are demand forecast a
traffic forecast
you could see
and can make a good case for
demand side metrics as being a driver
for
upgrades to ftth
and
upgrades within ftth from gpon to
xgspawn and so forth
and you know we do traffic forecasts we
do traffic analysis and traffic
forecasts and
you know on the left-hand side you've
got european average data usage per
fixed broadband line this isn't the
fiber line this is just fixed broadband
and the average last year was somewhere
around about 350 gigabytes across the
whole of europe it's a lot higher in
some countries it's over what over half
a terabyte in some countries
but uh that that's that that's the how
it was last year and of course last year
and the year before were pretty
exceptional
and uh as everyone knows
uh fixed traffic growth
fixed data traffic grew at a super
normal rate
um
having said that you know there's some
interesting trends within that one is
that mobile that actually during the
pandemic at least the world stopped
going mobile
in safari's mobile network's share of
total traffic
didn't grow in fact it shrank slightly
within europe
so that's an interesting trend and we
actually see
long-term convergence of the growth
rates of fixed and mobile traffic
with fixed being about 10 times higher
um
secondly uh and perhaps surprisingly we
don't see
strong evidence for
um uplink growing faster than downlink
it certainly did during the pandemic
uh it grew
at a far faster rate than downlink
but long term we don't see strong
evidence for that actually happening
it's a good story but we don't see
evidence for it yet
so
you know
we think it's prudent to sort of suggest
25
compound annual growth rate on fixed
traffic 25 to 30 maybe something like
that
got 29 there but
who knows and who knows what
the metaverse might throw up
in terms of
expectations and traffic
um
what can be said for certain about the
metaverse
though is that it will be far more to do
with ftth and wi-fi than it ever is to
do with 5g
it is you know it'll be overwhelmingly
driven and used and utilized on fixed
networks
okay so you could make an argument to
say that these demand trends translate
into
into uh
a justification for trap for
uh um technology upgrades
both to ftth and within ftgh
and that can be something of a
convoluted argument that there's a there
is a comfort speed that we can identify
below which
um users average usage falls off
in other words this is the speed at
which people need people um
have enough bandwidth more or less to do
what they want there'll be exceptions
but that's more or less it
and that there is a top tier speed
which is driven by customer expectations
of what operators offer rather than
their own personal need
which is
maybe 10 times higher than the comfort
speed
and on that basis you could sort of
start justifying
justifying upgrades to xgs pawn which is
already underway of course
and beyond that two to 25 g pawn or 50g
pawn in the future
but it's a convoluted argument
and it's one that um
involves a little bit of intellectual
reverse engineering i'd say
um as do do
forecasts which depend very heavily on
um an understanding of a very tech tech
savvy comp uh family in the future it's
kind of a bit of reverse engineering
the reality is that the incremental cost
of capacity of speed
uh the capital cost is plummeting and
that ramps up customer expectations it
continues to ramp up customer
expectations we're not really in an age
where
um
where
we're trying to match
bandwidth with customer
user
need any longer we're trying to match it
with customer expectation
and operator need to be competitive in
the market
that doesn't mean don't do upgrades it
means it's really in a sense out a plea
from a plea to say let's be realistic
about what actually drives
these technology upgrades
now
perhaps more compelling
are the arguments around efficiency
okay for upgrades both to ftth and
within ftth
um first of all on the left you'd have a
you know just a simple idea of the total
cost of ownership of transport
of one gigabyte of data
on
uh at a 40 utilized network so you could
look at 5g
a 5g with a radio upgrade 5g with a new
site
or
gpon with
a new built odn
uh or a straight to xgs pawn
implementation you can see that there's
a huge difference there are two two
orders of magnitude difference in terms
of the efficiency
the total cost of ownership and that's
even taking that is a total cost of
ownership figure taking into account the
capital cost
um
and
uh in terms of network opex
um just network optics savings on repair
and maintenance we've got a few figures
there they all mean something slightly
different but we're getting a view that
in terms of network opex you know there
are savings to be made of 50
70
so forth uh in terms of that's really
effectively network maintenance capex
and fault
um troubleshooting
and that's not even including the
additional op
additional non-network opex savings you
might make from lower churn or something
like that
that that amounts to maybe 30 to 50
euros per year
per line per home past
so you know pretty significant changes
and bottom right we've got
um power consumption per per per
connection
um
divided into network and
cpe um and
[Music]
you know power consumption on fixed
networks is never the largest element in
an integrated operator's environment
mobile consumes far more power than fix
does whether it's copper or fiber
but
you can see
quite clearly how
how the efficiency
and this is really important in the
context not only of of of the green
agenda and sustainability but also just
in terms of the the massive
spikes in in energy prices and
volatility
energy prices at the moment this is
really very important
so i'd say you know technology choices
have to be based on a little bit more
than customer
customer demand customer demand and is
part of it competitiveness and
efficiency are
are just as important if not more so
um so
um i think it's pretty clear where we're
heading
at the moment uh uh and that's kind of
ubiquitous ubiquitous fiber connectivity
to the home or very near ubiquitous
you know really high 90s
uh
connectivity
you know there's been a if you look back
over 15 to 20 years the proportion of
households that people thought weren't
that operators or policy makers thought
weren't viable for ftth
or
sensible recipients of
of public funding for ftch that's
continued to shrink
and if you extrapolate those trends it's
going towards zero
we would expect in the end
pretty much every premises in europe to
be passed by ftth
um
and
that means
copper to ftth
upgrades of course and that's already
well underway it means hfc
to uh
ftth upgrades
which is beginning to happen in earnest
in the last two years we're seeing a lot
of cable operators
making that bold decision to upgrade to
to to ftth not all of them
and not universe not not not
consistently across the world
certainly
um and i think there's a third element
of that we would actually see in the
long run fwa
to
ftth upgrades in those areas where fwa
is
deployed as a lower cost sub substitute
for for fdth at the moment so we'd see
5g 5g's roll in fixed line shrinking
a long run
um
so um and it's pretty clear where
operators need to be they need to be
uh
they need to be
by the end of the decade they sort of
need need to be
industry best in terms of performance
uh uh
resilience opex environmental impact
you know they need that picture to be
they need a road map to that to that end
point
um
so
in a sense
where are the
uncertainties you know perhaps we've
reached a point where there aren't
uncertainties i'd say well there are
actually two major sets of uncertainties
one is still how we get there most
efficiently now that's a mixture of
business models it's a matter of
regulation it's a matter of policy and
it's a matter of technology choices
but in particular the business models is
about you know how you
whether it's a wholesale uh open access
model a wholesale only model a
vertically integrated model or so forth
and so forth even when it comes down to
wholesaling what do you actually sell is
it layer one is it layer two is it layer
three
is it uh a network as a service uh sort
of softwareized version of that
these are these are important these are
important considerations
and there are technology choices
involved in that
the second
major set of uncertainties is
how we make best and fullest use of
those networks
once they're in place
and i think that's largely around
technology choices
so to put a bit more
color on that
you know these are the
i was asked to talk about technology
here not not business models
particularly so uh um
these are the sets of technology choices
we understand
the three on the the right hand side
from 12 o'clock down to six o'clock as
it were
are ones around
how we how we get there
um
the ones on the from six o'clock up to
12 o'clock are about really about how we
make best best and most efficient use of
what we've actually already got
um
so there are build and plan aspects to
this and technology choices that are
that are there in terms of capex
minimization and avoidance the use of
software
maybe prefabrication maybe not you know
there's a there's a tco argument around
that
which is which is complex
then of course there's the roadmap for
the access technologies themselves which
are you know clear we've mentioned those
before the road map for xgs pond 25 50
100 gpon the use of coherent
technologies for for mobile transport
even within that as well
then there's the choice of the indoor
network
uh infrastructure and technology
usually revolving around wi-fi 6 wi-fi
6e wi-fi 7
use of cloud management and so forth but
also increasingly
thoughts around it especially around the
the ftf f5g vision of fiber to the
everywhere fiber to the room the
densification of the network within
uh properties within of the fixed
network within properties rather than
reliance on wireless
of passive optical lands within an
enterprise or or
business environment those are important
technology choices but perhaps the most
important choice really long run
is the software layer the network
control the readiness for new cases that
might come along
the readiness for new b2c sudden shifts
in b2c demand
around latency or jitter for
virtual reality services or something
like that
some unexpected shift that might come
along
but also readiness for
novel use cases for non-b2c use cases
where virtual network operators
have
can architect the the network for new
services for other virtual network
operators to provide allowing them to
create
and tune services according to their
needs
without
the intermediary of a wholesale without
the
operational intermediary of a wholesale
operator in its catalogue of services
and as a final part of the jigsaw um
the answer there's a sort of uncertainty
in where we're heading is is the
integration with other parts of the
telecoms network the ftth network with
other parts of the telecoms network now
i heard yesterday somebody saying we
shouldn't talk about ftth plays we
should talk about fiber infrastructure
plays and it's about you know how you
integrate that ftth part of the part of
the equation with the other parts of the
fiber network and indeed actually for
integrated operators how you best
integrate that with the cellular network
and as a final thought on that you know
perhaps we're heading
to a less
sort of mobile-centric vision of
of of telecoms networks in the future
um
where
we're heading perhaps towards a a world
where there is the possibility of a more
efficient and more sustainable mix
based on what is efficient
of a 5g or 6 future 6g of ftth and wi-fi
so that's my conclusion so thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you